forgiveness is an important expression
of generosity of giving now it doesn't
mean that you need to be naive it
doesn't mean that forgiveness is as easy
as the forgiveness researchers suggest
that's the thing I would say you know I
think to some degree forgiveness became
a little bit of a cottage industry in
the late 90s and folks came out with all
kinds of quick self-help books on how to
be forgiving here are the four stages
yada yada yada the reality is that when
you've really been harmed by someone
when the hurt is deep and profound these
two easy approaches don't do much so
what I argue and I believe have shown is
that the best way to really get through
those deeper hurts you know is first of
all to concentrate on contributing to
the lives of others because that gets
the mind off the self and the problems
of the self you find a gratification in
benefiting the people around you so it's
very very good the other thing is let
time work its magic because the longer
you get away from that point that
epicenter of deep hurt once upon a time
a year ago or two years ago or three
years ago you know you you have a better
chance of reinterpreting it and asking
yourself well maybe I could have handled
this a little differently maybe I
shouldn't be demonizing that individual
maybe it was something that I could have
said a little better or looked at a
little differently or interpreted
differently so so I think that's it I
think the key to forgiveness is giving
it time and making sure that you're
enough focused on helping others that
you just don't get so wrapped up in
yourself that you're just you're caught
up in destructive emotions because
everybody knows that hostile emotions
and
bitterness rumination are very very bad
for your health especially for your your
heart your vasculature system in fact
there was a cardiologist at Duke who
looked back at people who took the
Minnesota multiphasic personality
inventory in 1950 this thing the MMPI is
the kind of a personality questionnaire
with about 350 questions the the high
quartile hostels he picked out 27
questions that really denoted high
hostility quickly angered hot-tempered
prone to violence unforgiving and so
forth if you were a high hostel you had
a 20% mortality rate by age 50 he took
25 year olds in 1950 and then this is
all retrospective looks at them in 1975
when they're 51 out of five are dead
mainly of heart disease a lot of
cortisol coming out enlarged adrenals
fatty acids in the vasculature system
very serious problem now the low
quartile hostels had a two percent
mortality rate which gives a little
added meaning to the statement go with
the flow but basically I think yeah when
you when you move out of that space of
dark destructive emotion into helping
others where you know as they say in
psychology you know your emotions follow
your actions so you don't necessarily
have to go to the mountains in Colorado
and meditate on compassion if you just
do small acts of generosity in an active
way your emotions tend to follow you
that's called the james-lange theory of
emotions it's why people say even if
you're not happy in the morning smile
you